Four years ago I uploaded a video explaining
how Littlefinger might have caused Robert's
Rebellion,
it was well received and well liked theory.
Now that House of the Dragon is coming in
just over a year, that theory (if true) might
be more significant than ever before.
House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
It is based on George RR Martin’s book Fire
And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s yet unfinished
Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the
legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator of
the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount the
generations of Targaryens who fought to hold
that iconic seat, all the way up to the civil
war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
In other words it covers events from Aegon's
Conquest to the Dance of the Dragons.
Thats Fire And Blood volume 1.
House of the Dragon will start with a build
up towards the Dance of the Dragons and early
seasons will cover the Dance itself. Later
seasons however, will be based on George RR
Martin’s yet unfinished Fire And Blood volume
2 book .
The yet unreleased Fire And Blood volume 2
will continue from where part 1 ended, with
Rhaenyra Targaryen's son Aegon lll's reign
and will cover Blackyre rebellions, war with
Dorne and go all the way to the Mad King and
Robert's Rebellion that ended Targaryen dynasty.
In this video I'm going to tell you a theory
of mine that I came up with 4 years ago
in which Littlefinger caused Robert's Rebellion
and ultimately the end of the Targaryens.
Since the first season of Game of Thrones
we have learned that Petyr Baelish is a cunning,
unpredictable and ruthless manipulator of
court politcs. As Varys observed himself,
Littlefinger is a grasper from a minor House
with great skill at befriending and eventually
maneuvering powerful people.
His treatment by the Tullys when he was a
young man, and his near death at the hand
of Brandon Stark, embittered him against both,
the Tullys and the Starks. Littlefinger had
orchestrated the entire War of the Five Kings,
the war in which tens of thousands of soldiers
and civilians died. Littlefinger`s, we can
call it genius plan back in season 1, was
to kill Jon Arryn with the help of Jon`s own
wife, which he did,
and then to make Ned Stark as the new hand
of the king, whereupon he helped Ned to figure
out who Joffrey`s real father was. Littlefinger
knew that it would lead honorable Ned to reveal
the truth to everyone else, which led to King
Robert Baratheon`s death as well as to Ned
Stark`s beheading , which started the War
of the Five Kings. Littlefinger also made
it seem like Lannisters tried to kill Bran
when in fact it was his doing. Long story
short, Littlefinger threw the Seven Kingdoms
into the state of chaos from which he personally
benefited. Let me highlight one Varys`s qoute
regarding Littlefinger - ``Littlefinger was
born with no lands, no wealth, no armies.
He's acquired the first two. How long before
he has the army? Perhaps you`ll laugh, but
I know him better than most, and this is the
truth. Littlefinger is one of the most dangerous
men in Westeros.``And let me also say that
this conversation between Varys and Olenna
took place in the fourth episode of the third
season. Meanwhile Littlefinger married Lysa
Tully, widow of Lord Jon Arryn of the Vale
who poisoned Jon on Littlefinger`s order,
and therefore Petyr Baelish became the Lord
Protector of the Vale. As Varys said, Littlefinger
became very powerful man with lands and wealth,
and even managed to provide himself an army
that he's basically commanding, which he made
possible by influencing the young lord Robin,
the new Lord Paramount of the Vale. Petyr
Baelish also did all he could to set Sansa
as a Queen in the North.
He betrayed Ned Stark in order to set up a
fight between "wolfs" and "lions", poisoned
Jofrrey at Joffrey`s own wedding with the
help of Olenna Tyrell to "save" Sansa and
then handed her over to Boltons. All in order
to turn the North against the Boltons, and
to give him an opportunity to lead the knights
of the Vale that he is commanding, by manipulating
young lord Robin, which he provided by killing
Robin`s father and mother. All of this was
in order to set Sansa as the Queen in the
North, convinced that it would lead to marriage
between him and the new Queen of the North,
which would provide him northern army and
thus one step closer to the Iron Throne. As
we saw in the season 6 finale, in the battle`s
aftermath, Littlefinger approached Sansa in
the Godswood and admitted that his goal is
to sit on the Iron Throne with her by his
side, with her as his queen. However, despite
him being arguably the most cunning and the
most intelligent player in the game, Baelish
is not incapable of making mistakes and his
plan to manipulate Sansa failed when the all
seeing Bran Stark returned home. With all
of this being said, let`s see if there's any
evidence that Petyr Baelish, beside orchestrating
a major civil war in the Seven Kingdoms, known
as the War of the Five Kings, also orchestrated
the great civil war among the Great Houses
of Westeros, known as the War of the Usurper
or more popularly, Robert`s Rebellion. As
we all know, Robert`s rebellion resulted in
the collapse of the Targaryen dynasty and
the ascension of Robert Baratheon to the Iron
Throne. I know that most of you are probably
confused at this point and are probably wondering
why would have and how could have he orchestrated
Robert`s rebellion. Well, it`s actually pretty
simple, and there are two reasons, revenge
and benefit, and in the following minutes
you will be introduced with how exactly he
might have done it.
Petyr`s father served well under Lord Hoster
Tully and through their good relationship
Hoster agreed to foster his son Petyr at Riverrun,
which was a great honor for House Baelish.
Petyr went to Riverrun when he was eight years
old and there he befriended Hoster`s daughters
Catelyn and Lysa Tully, while their brother
Edmure mockingly nicknamed him ``Littlefinger``,
the nickname that would stick with him through
his entire life. Petyr became obsessed with
Catelyn, but she never returned his affections.
Eventually when she was engaged to Brandon
Stark, Ned`s older brother, heir to Lord of
Winterfell and Lord Paramount of the North,
Petyr challenged him to a duel. Brandon defeated
Baelish easily, nearly disemboweling him in
the process, but Catelyn begged Brandon to
spare his life. The maesters were able to
save Baelish and he eventually recovered,
but he was left with a deep scar running from
his stomach to his collarbone, a token from
Brandon that Baelish would carry with him.
After this, Baelish was cast out of Riverrun
and returned to Vale. Later, Brandon Stark
who had been on his way to Riverrun to wed
Catelyn Tully was enraged due to false information
about Prince Rhaegar Targaryen`s abduction
over his sister Lyanna, and instead to Riverrun,
he rode to King`s Landing immediately to demand
Rhaegar`s arrest and punishment. Aerys ``the
Mad King`` arrested Brandon for treason and
eventually killed him and his father Rickard
in a horrific and unjust way, which led to
Houses Baratheon, Stark and Arryn rebelling
against the Iron Throne. Now, in my opinion,
those false rumors about Rhaegar`s abduction
over Lyanna that basically started Robert`s
Rebellion were started by none other than
Petyr Baelish himself. As we learned in later
seasons of Game of Thrones, Rhaegar did not
kidnap Lyanna, but they rather loved each
other and went away together. However it's
still unknown why they decided to leave without
a word, knowing this could start a war. Knowing
how kind and noble Rhaegar and Lyanna were,
it`s also hard to believe they would let the
Seven Kingdoms as well as their own families
burn for their love. On the one hand we have
Brandon who at a time had been on his way
to Riverrun to wed Catelyn Tully, while on
the other hand we have Lyanna who was in the
Riverlands when she departed with Rhaegar
to the Tower of Joy. When you take a close
look, it does seem possible that Littlefinger
spread the false rumors of Rhaegar abducting
Lyanna in order to prevent a wedding between
his beloved Catelyn and Brandon Stark as well
as to seek revenge against Brandon who almost
killed him sometime earlier. Now before I
go any further, let me just show you one clip
from the third episode of the very first season
that's going in favor to this theory.
As we can see, Eddard was furious when Littlefinger
brought him to a brothel, believing that he
is a victim of a bad joke, but Catelyn intervened
when Ned attacked Littlefinger,
whereupon Littlefinger said ``the Starks..
quick tempers, slow minds``.
Could it be that Littlefinger spread false
rumors about Rhaegar`s abduction over Lyanna
Stark knowing that it would lead quick tempered
Brandon Stark who was also known as the wild
wolf
to do something honorable and stupid at the
same time, which would result with Brandon
not continuing his travel to Riverrun to wed
Catelyn, but instead to ride to King`s Landing
and eventually die, which is exactly what
happened. Could it be that this Littlefinger`s
quote about the Starks was actually a foreshadow
of Ned Stark`s death, because just as Brandon,
Ned Stark had a quick temper,
but slow mind to figure out Littlefinger`s
manipulation. In the seventh episode of the
first season, Littlefinger said there's one
thing he learned from losing his duel to Brandon
Stark,
he learned that he will never win on their,
honorable way,but will rather as he said himself
- manipulate them to provide himself everything
he wants, which at first was Catelyn Tully
and revenge against Brandon Stark. There is
a high possibility that Littlefinger did spread
false rumours about Rhaegar`s kidnap over
Lyanna in order to prevent Brandon Stark`s
marriage with his beloved Catelyn,
since he knew Brandon had a quick temper,which
instead of thinking twice about his next act
resulted with him riding to King`s Landing
immediately and demanding justice from the
Mad King,
which resulted just as Littlefinger wanted,
with Brandon’s death. There's one more fact
that is going in favor to this theory, which
is confirmation of Petyr Baelish knowing that
Rhaegar did not abduct Lyanna, which the forth
episode of the fifth season almost certainly
confirmed.
There's a scene in which Petyr finds Sansa
in the crypts of Winterfell paying her respects
to her deceased family members. Petyr recalls
about how Rhaegar Targaryen chose Sansa's
aunt, Lyanna, which started Robert’s rebellion
against the Targaryen family,
on which Sansa replied with confirming that
Rhaegar did choose her aunt, but against her
will,
on which Littlefinger didn’t reply, but
he didn’t even have to, his face expression
was more than enough.
Littlefinger had known the truth. How did
Littlefinger know the truth in the first place
to be able to twist it around and spread false
information you might wonder - well, there
are many possibilities.
Littlefinger like Varys is known to have spies
everywhere, so that's one possibility.
The other possibility is that he himself saw
them run away.
The third, more complicated possibility is
that Littfinger intercepted Lyanna's message
or letter that was meant for her brother Brandon
in which she wrote that she and Rhaegar are
in love and will spend some time together,
making sure no bad assumptions arise to start
a war, but Littlfinger simply burned the letter
and spread the false rumor. I’m convinced
that Littlefinger spread the false rumours
about Rhaegar’s abduction over Lyanna to
prevent Brandon from marrying his beloved
Catelyn and to get Brandon killed,
while also starting a civil war from which
he would benefit as after the war he joins
the small council.
He did always say that chaos benefits him.
House of the Dragon airs in 2022 and since
the later seasons will cover Robert's Rebellion,
I’m looking forward to find out why Lyanna
had not left a simple note for her family
that could have prevented the death of her
father and brother as well as the deaths of
thousands of soldiers and innocent people
that died during Robert’s Rebellion. There's
a possibility that Lyanna wrote a note,
but it was simply handed over to the wrong
person and was never read by the Starks.
I'm convinced Littlefinger caused Robert's
Rebellion for revenge and benefit.
Thank you so much for watching, hope you enjoyed
this video and if you did make sure to give
it a big thumbs up and I hope to see you in
the next one, peace!